[Musique]
alors c'est parti pour l'ouverture des
cadeaux on commence par l'arbre à chat
et tu content yes autour de soi d'un
bassin marcy trois deux un yes merlas ya
un petit cadeau pour toi les chats ont
vraiment une logique implacable
j'adore ce carton on le petit tunnel oui
bravo je vais vous tapez olympique
saucisses ou les gares ou une petite
[ __ ] pour chats encore un truc bien
chiant à monter quand ça perd trop
compliqué à savoir qu'on sait le début
des embrouilles génial c'est parti pour
l'atelier pliage douane ils traités
light et le type epr est énorme tipi en
carton de teu teu teu teu teu teu c'est
un succès énorme succès du tipi comme il
va ce qui prend du plaisir
tout tout tout alors ça c'est un petit
vêtement spécial m charest dire donc que
collection automne hiver avec des petits
pompons pas tant mais j'ai directement
le m tiens je dois ôté mon petit plus le
poisson jeu des gouttes m tu pourras
faute et john hope attention et marie
non vraiment ça c'est une petite sacoche
pour le transporter comme un kangourou
tu as c'est le moment de tester tu vas
vu une expérience mon pote tu imagines
même pas du tout voilà ouais bon renard
crédit ou par forme cet apéro ouais on
fait un truc on boit du schweppes
[ __ ] mais je le portais de tous les
jours c'est sûr aux objets suivants face
une sorte de petit fromage ou et des
souris qui sortent c'est un peu la ps4
des chats c'est ultra moyens que les
régimes immédiatement go
[Musique]
bon voilà c'est le même truc pendant 30
ans y'a pas un truc qui va changer de
notre coup c'est un transformers
alors ça devinez ce que c'est et bien
c'est une brosse achats en forme de
langues de chat whist objets inutiles
c'est écrit aux lakers
c'est à dire lâche ton chat mer là tu
veux que tu saches le but visé mardi
[Musique]
il est vraiment bas des douze bon bah
c'est sans fin sans le lécher donc cet
objet a été validé à 8%
next ce sont des sacs de transport pour
chaque astronaute donc celui ci un peu
plus ambiant ce jules verne ou 59° et
c'est l'actuel petit hublot ou le chat
mais sa tête qui dépasse
ok ok premier sac montée au bout de huit
ans aura je tiens à préciser qu' aucun
de ces objets est un passe temps de
produire ses cadets petit kiff des
petits achats coup de coeur sac numéro
deux montées je tiens tu préfères or on
voit finalement le vert allez c'est
parti pour le jeu sans que ça va
clairement est une catastrophe
et contre toute attente ce chat est
temps qu'ils total j'espérais que ça
incroyable et tellement o'keefe absolue
à la je dis peut-être qu'à une arnaque
en effet y avait bien une arnaque mais
s'est fait piéger est-ce qu'on peut
mettre aussi son ordinateur ça trouve
c'est tout d'envoi genre le mec il a 30
ans vient de trousses quoi aller je met
sur le dos et je vais au travail
manon j'ai pas de travail si lily bon je
vous laisse je ne sais rien
[Musique]
à
allez on va libérer le pauvre ça n'a
duré que cinq minutes c'est bon tacle un
coup oui j'ai avec des poteaux qu'on a
contacté sur internet qui fabrique des
sortes de circuits pour chad et des
trucs pour les ja bon ça part un peu
chelou comme ça mais ça va rendre un
truc de ouf
ben on va laisser s'installer parce que
s'arrête la fin ça c'est pas que je
préfère donc tu veux faire sûrement de
vous aider parce que me suis très nul en
bricolage
allez les gars on s'active un petit peu
plus rapide fiable et pour ça que c'est
un peu gros quand à vous c'est 100 fois
plus gros que j'imaginais mais on a
quand même dit en fait il ya carrément
lieu de télécommande pour changer la
couleur du logo m
comme merlin le rouge ces genres et les
occuper et le verglas les dispos c'est
comme un taxi quoi
[Musique]
en bon